so I'm going to talk about Apache spark
and why I think that it makes a really
powerful platform for building
distributed machine learning systems I
can just about me so longtime user a
spark I organized the London spark
Meetup by the way so if anyone finds
this interesting then do come to the
meetup and I run the data item Skimlinks
so Skimlinks we are let's just say we
ran our tech company we mainly deal with
very large quantities of text data
websites we analyze lots of it we
analyze around something like a billion
very small documents a day and so we're
using spark to build systems that can
analyze that text and in the main you
can think of it as things like
classifying text according to what topic
that that piece of text is about okay so
really over the last year interest in
spark has gone a bit crazy and it's for
things like this this is this is the the
daytona grace hawk benchmark from last
year once got the team from data briggs
won the competition and they so they
they sorted a hundred terabytes of data
in 23 minutes using two hundred machines
and the previous record was this harding
for implementation a seventy two minutes
with two thousand machines so everyone's
excited it looks interesting and i think
that a lot of this bars is quite
justified so i'm just going to go
through some really basic concepts that
you need to understand and know what
spock does I'll go through this quite
quick who's actually used spark before
ok so I want spend loads of time on this
but I just bring everyone up to speed so
this is a central concept
it's the RDD so resilient distributed
data so I think that really this is just
a way of distributing a massive data so
of rows of data across a cluster of
machines and so you can see this kind of
rectangle and then these blue things are
supposed to represent what are known as
partitions and you can sort of think of
them as files and then this will be
distributed
the whole cluster but that's invisible
to you really all you know is that it's
a big it's a large number of partitions
or files distributed across your cluster
where you don't know which thing is on
which which machine so this is some
spark code some PI spark code its first
on this laser pointer so this first line
is just a way out I've just made an
artificial RDD in this case I've just
taken 12 numbers and distributes them
across the cluster
obviously you don't you do this if you
have more than 12 numbers but just for
this example I've made swap numbers and
I've distributed them into four
partitions those were those blue things
that I showed you on the last slide and
then after I distribute it I just bring
it back to the master node and this is
just a normal pie thinlits now it's just
12 numbers so what can you do with these
rdd's so this is a another key this is a
key function map everything fits in so
the MapReduce framework that you're
probably familiar with already and here
I'm just running a map with a function a
lambda function that takes the modulus
of a number we take them
it's the modulus three of the number so
with this list
it applies this function to every single
element of this list and it gives me
this result as you would expect and it's
completely element wise at this station
this map is as an element-wise
operation it applies to each element
separately so that's what this indicates
like all of these partitions can be
processed completely separately and
independently across the cost analysis
it's nice and clean so now I'm zipping
these two lists together this is normal
and it this is similar to the Python zip
built in you know the first elements are
0 1 2 0 1 2 0 1 2 and then the other
elements of 0 2 that's what 0 to 11
so I've just paired up those two lists
and now I'm collecting I collect them
onto the male so you can see them and
then I'm introducing this other really
important function which is reduced by
key and this is this is a bit like
reduce in Hadoop if you're familiar with
that paradigm I'm just going to apply
this reduction I'm going to reduce using
this function they eat for all of the
elements which are associated with each
of the keys so there are three distinct
keys here 0 1 2 and you can see like if
we just go through the first one the
first pair is 0 18 if you look here you
can see 0 0 0 keys are 0 the values for
the 0 key are 0 3 6 9 is 0
yeah 3 6 and 9 and that adds up to 18
and the same thing for 126 and really
once you understand those two things you
can do nearly everything you need to in
spark it's just MapReduce but something
Keeler you need to understand is that
when you do this reduced by key thing
you know for instance the 0 Keys may be
on any partition and they may be on any
machine so you have to you have to do
what's called a shuffle and the data
will have to go between machines which
is what this kind of these arrows are
supposed to indicate that there's a lot
of intima scheen communication happening
and in the main this is something to be
avoided when you can't because it takes
a lot of i/o network traffic and you
start you may see some suffering and
performance if you do lots of shuffling
on very very large data sets and by
large just to give you some sense we are
looking around 30 terabytes of data on
40 node clusters that's what we think of
is a large like net over 10 or 20
terabytes of data is a lot of data for
SPARC to deal with and you need to start
thinking about how to you know design
your system so that they work well in so
much data
when you start using spark on large data
sets you that will definitely crush a
lot and there was here are some kind of
rules of thumb that well were thinking
about so make sure you set the number of
reducers sensibly and I'll talk about
that little bit more detail later
configure the spark cluster properly
I'll talk about that too - awful I've
mentioned don't group by I won't go into
details there but you can I'm not going
to go into lots of the functions that
you can do on ideas some things we're
boring but you can look at the
documentation you just don't do group by
and repartition your data if you need to
and by that I just mean in there in my
original example I'd for blue blocks for
partitions you can increase that number
of partitions by a function called we
partition which will then you can
increase the number of partitions and a
shuffle will take place but by having
very small partitions you may get better
performance which is something to bear
in mind so what happens is you know you
will have some power times when you're
using PI spark and people will come to
you and they will say why are you using
Python it's written in Scala it's just
not gonna work on Python I say don't
listen to those people because when you
actually talk to them in detail you
realize they look they're suffering from
all the same problems that you are it's
just that to you spark really
effectively you need to understand
what's going on under the hood filled
very large data sets so I'm going to
talk all the graphic hasn't come out
very well here but I'm going to talk
through an example of how you might
implemented machine learning algorithm
in spark I'm choosing very simple
example which is naive Bayes I know it's
a slightly boring algorithm to go
through but it's quite simple and I
think it illustrates some of the design
choices that you might want to make when
you're when you're making this kind of
distributed system so I'm just going to
recap naive face this is this is a
simple application of Bayes rule you
have a sequence of features in this case
in our case numbers which are the X's
and a class
which is the C so the probability of a
particular class is equal to this thing
on the right which is the prior
probability of being a member of the
class and then the likelihood which is
the probability of seeing your
observations given conditional on the
class on the class being K and then it's
divided by this constant which we are
going to so here it's just represented
as a proportion without the constant and
we'll implement it using the logs of the
numbers so that we don't have problems
with underflow this is how you don't
Spock this is how I represent this get
tokens function just basically takes
lots of documents and then represents
them as a label so supervised learning
so I have a label and then it's and then
the token so that's what this RDD looks
like obviously be along be a lot bigger
reality and then I kind of transform it
a little bit using this map function to
this new data structure where I have
each token and then I have lists with
two numbers in it and those numbers
represent whether that whether that
token is labeled true or false that's
that's that's supposed to indicate the
class membership and what I'm really
doing is I'm trying to create some
counters so I can count how many times
the word address for instance is found
in the positive class compared to the
negative class and this is a slightly
weird way of doing things you might
think in Python you'd probably wonder
like this you'd kind of iterate over
there over there over the original list
and build up some data structure using
some dicks or something like that you
can't you can't do that in spark because
the data is distributed over the cluster
and you don't have a like a distributive
dictionary that you can use you have to
build up your data structures in this
kind of functional way using using
reduce and that's what I do in this next
step this reduce by key I simply apply
this function
lambda function which is just going to
apply this is just a Python built-in map
but now I'm just going to add all of the
contents of all of the elements of X or
all of the elements of Y in an
element-wise way so that means and you
do that for all of the contents all of
the values for each of the keys so all
I'm doing here is just adding up for the
word dress how many times it occurs in a
positive class compared to a negative
class and in this case five times it
occurs in a document labeled positive 15
times in a document labeled negative
then I'm not going to go through this
I'm just adding one basically to the
elements of this list as a pseudo count
which is sometimes very useful in this
kind of problem
it's a smoothing and then I get the
total number of words in each class and
this is a kind of design pattern I guess
that you'll see a lot I'm just taking a
lambda I take these elements and I just
throw away this element there and make a
new data structure which is just two
counts in full scale so it starts off
term two counts force counts and it ends
up just being true counts and full
scales I'm just throwing away the term
basically in order that I can do another
reduce and add up all of their numbers
together to get the totals because in
the algorithm you need to know what the
totals how many words in total you got
in the positive class how many was in
total you got in the negative class in
order that you can find the probability
of a particular word in a particular
class don't worry about the details I
know it's a bit hairy but I just want to
illustrate how simple it is in just a
couple of lines to make this kind of
distributed algorithm work so this is
something that's very important to
understand about the way the SPOC work
so you will be doing reduced by keys all
the time in spark and it's important to
understand how it actually works so you
can get by if you're looking at data of
around six
the gigs you don't really need to know
this kind of stuff but if you're looking
at very large datasets unless you really
understand this it's going to it's going
to you're going to crush quite a lot so
this is to illustrate what actually
happens when you do something like
reduce by key what happens is a
dictionary is created on each partition
on each machine that the partition is
residence on a Python process will do a
reduce on the partition all the examples
I've had so far they've used by been
addition so let's just say additions I'm
adding up these keys k1 in this case I
add up the values to k1 which gives me 2
here 3 there and 5 there and that's fine
that's just that because that's just
happening on the pods on them on the map
side on a single machine it's not
computationally intensive things won't
crush but what happens after that is
that a shuffle takes place where all of
the keys for all of the K ones are
distributed to a specific reducer in
this case the first reducer and when
that happens all of these keys are being
shuffled all on the network lots of
files being created our memory starts to
run out and issues happen so it's very
important that you set the number of
partitions correctly using this function
I'm aware that if you've never used
spart before this probably doesn't mean
much to you but it's something that that
really matters when you're doing large
data sets but not only do you need to
look at the number of partitions you
also need to look at the number of input
partitions so this non partitions
argument is very important but it won't
solve all of your problems you also need
to understand you need to make sure that
you don't have too many partitions
actually as input to the so they're
reduced by key for large data sets so
you know that's a kind of naive
implementation and it works reasonably
well using the reduce by key but it is
doing all of this network traffic which
is not very nice and you want to try and
avoid as much as possible so there's
another way there's another option for
doing this kind of aggregation and
to use the aggregate function so this
this is this is the API documentation it
says it aggregates the elements of each
partition and then the results for all
the partitions using a given combined
function on a neutral zero value so you
basically need some create some kind of
class which has a sec or function and a
combo function and then aggregate will
apply your functions to partitions and
then apply the Kalmbach so all of the
aggregation classes so this is an
example of an aggregator you need to
write your own aggregator and all you
need to do is have an odd function and a
merge function and all the add function
does is takes in a row of data from an
RDD and adds it to this aggregating
class and in this case everything is
just at being aggregated in this diction
in this dictionary here and called s and
all out does is take in a row of data
and adds it to Rho s I won't go through
the code the merge function takes in one
of these aggregator objects and adds it
to the original aggregator some object
so you're just adding two aggregator
objects together the upshot of all of
this is that you now have large objects
which contain dictionaries with the data
in them instead of having lots of rows
of data which need to be distributed all
over the network
you've only you may let's say you have
six thousand partitions you know only
have six thousand objects to distribute
over though over the cluster rather than
four billion rows of data being
distributed all over the cluster so they
should not the you know that should be
quite nice this is how you use a I'll go
over this in detail you can look at the
API documentation and anyway when I try
to implement this using a billion
documents it just didn't work
and everything crushed so what don't you
know don't use I could go and this is
the reason why that is these are these
are supposed to be the partitions these
circles on the bottom so aggregation
will aggregate all of the all of the
members of a partition to create an
aggregation object so there will be if
there are six thousand partitions you'll
end up with six thousand aggregation
objects and all that and put them all
onto the master node there's only four
there but if there were six thousand the
master node it's going to run out of
memory because these are quite big
objects they may have you know maybe a
dictionary was two million words you
know something
so doesn't work but the design is a
spark of thought about this and there
was a new function in spark called tree
aggregation tree aggregate which does
exactly the same thing as aggregate but
does it over a tree structure and all
that means is that instead of just
aggregating all of the partitions or all
of the elements of each partition
separately and then putting them all
onto the master it does it in an
iterative manner aggregating each
partition separately first and then
aggregating a couple of partitions
together and then aggregating a couple
of partitions more and you can have like
called tall trees which means that
there's distribution the computation is
spread out and you don't get this
horrible effect of lots of big aggregate
objects being collected onto the master
node this is how you use it so I tested
this on a billion short documents say
ten words long using them reduced by key
method took eighteen minutes and this
tree aggregate method took about ten
minutes but I have to be honest and I
had to pack away a little bit and I had
to modify the actual API of spark to get
this to work and I put that in a gist I
won't go into details about what I had
to do is actually just a very simple
one-line change but this is a new
function I think the concept is really
interesting and something worth
considering and when you're implementing
a new algorithm
but but it's a new functionality and
usability were careful so I was gonna
talk about what to Veck but it seems
like everyone's talked about what about
to death so I'm not going to go into
loads of detail but this is maybe this
is a nice illustration of how you can
actually use this in practice I'm not
going to talk about this people have
talked about that but I'll but you know
what avec is a really nice algorithm
right and it's works very nicely in a
parallel setting there is a an
implementation in spark and this is how
you this is how you trainers it's I
guess it's four lines of code you could
train your own words avec vectors on a
cross on massive data sets which is
really really nice and then how do you
use these vectors in practice and people
haven't maybe haven't spoken about that
too much and I see there's three obvious
ways of refusing these factors one is
that you could just average vectors you
can take a sentence convert it into the
vector form and then just take average
over the you do element weights are
averaging over their vectors which might
work I've tried it and interesting to
work very well
or you can cluster the vectors
themselves to do these a kind of
dimensionality reduction which I will
talk about a little bit of detail or you
can use the compilation when your
network but I'm not going to talk about
that I'm going to talk about how you can
do this using spark by clustering so
spark has a very nice distributed
k-means function which you can use like
this i've just taken the pre-made
waterbuck vectors from google here and
used and use k-means in ml Lib to make
fifty thousand clusters and this is and
it worked
I think it took it like an hour or
something like that which is quite nice
because this is three million words
three hundred dimensions fifty thousand
cluster sensors there's quite a big job
I thought that was quite nice so the
idea is that I'm trying to find which
vectors are close to each other so that
I can then use them to to replace word
features so let's say you have a word
feature which is
- shoe or lace sole things to do with
Footwear this will hopefully replace all
of those individual words with one
cluster Center which will represent you
know footwear ship or something the idea
of being Footwear which is a
dimensionality reduction technique and
potentially can help with things like
classification problems so how do you
actually use this in practice I've made
my clusters I've made my postures after
making the clusters I now need to send
the clusters to and this is just going
to say send the clusters or the cluster
there's nothing very clear these my
cluster centers they came in a k-means
sense but I now want to send them to all
of the nodes our customer my cluster my
computational cluster and I do that
using this broadcast function and all
this all this does is it basically sends
any variable you like across the whole
of the cluster and then it means that
any map function that you then perform
has access to that variable which is
really useful because you know it means
you can do computation on them on the
master node make a big data structure
send it out to the cluster and then all
of the clusters or all of the nodes on
the cluster have access now to that
variable you can do some stuff you can
come back to the master node update that
data structure and then send it back out
to the cluster and then some more
computation can happen which is very
typical of the kinds of workflows that
you see in machine learning it's very
useful so now I'm going to talk a little
bit about how to modify the naive Bayes
algorithm that I just went over to do
semi-supervised learning so the naive
Bayes R group I gave you was a
supervisor algorithm you have a bunch of
labels and some data and you want to
build a classifier to classify documents
according to the label this
semi-supervised method was published in
2006 by these guys and it's a way of
really the algorithm just generates more
training data more label data based on
unlabeled later so you
give it some label dates as a seed set
and you give it a load of unlabeled data
and it will figure out a new set of
label data by predicting label data from
the unlabeled set and they always then
use that to retrain itself it's a
concept called self training and for
statisticians this is an instance of the
expectation maximization algorithm but
all you're really doing is in the East
at the first step you just run naive
Bayes on some label data create the cast
classifier then do some prediction on
all of your unlabeled data and then
treat your now labeled data as as label
data so now you have a much bigger set
of label data from your unlabeled data
the only slight wrinkle here is that you
have to you have to be able to predict
the probability that of class membership
in order to do this so you don't label
things according to true or false you
don't label them in a binary manner you
label them with a probability of
belonging to the positive class which
naive Bayes as a generously classifier
is quite quite sensible choice so the
only modification for the naive Bayes
implementation I gave is that instead of
now using these ones and zeros as class
membership you have these probabilities
so you go through this step where you
estimate what the probabilities of class
membership are and then urea stomates
again using the new labels this kind of
artificially labeled training set which
is really cool this is why SPARC is
really useful and in this kind of
problem because SPARC enables you to
keep your data set in memory so for this
kind of iterative process this is we're
looping over this right you might do
this a hundred times
SPARC keeps all of your data in memory
if you ask it to so you don't have the
hadoo problem of writing all of your
data l to disk reading back in again for
every iteration for so for most for many
machine learning algorithms such as the
ear
expectation-maximization algorithm spark
is a very very natural platform to use
I'll have some exam results so this is
for 500,000 labeled examples I have this
precision recall in f1 score and then by
adding 10 million unlabeled examples and
labeling them using them that a Bayes
classifier I'm just doing ten iterations
in this case I've increased the f1 by up
up to 0.14 it's labeled data for free
quite nice and this is this is not
interesting by I did this on a very
large data so this is like quarter of a
billion training examples and it didn't
seem to help anything and I think this
is because if you have very very many
training examples you don't need any I
mean
240 million training examples is enough
right you don't need anyone not are we
doing for time okay it's about
configuration now configuration I know
is boring you don't really need to
listen to this but if you do in the
future desire to use PI spark and you
have problems and things get bad and you
feel a bit depressed just remember there
you saw this guy I give this talk go
back to the slides and read the slides
because it will help you and make your
life better so this is how this is how
SPARC rugs you have your driver program
which is your master node and then the
cluster is distribution compensation is
happening over the cluster and you have
many worker nodes so that could be 20 or
40 worker nodes and these are individual
machines each one will typically have
one executor which is the process
actually performing computation and many
tasks you know if some it's a multi-core
machine it could have as many tosses it
has a cause for instance so what you
won't find online very often is how you
actually configure a spice bar cluster
but there's loads of information online
about how to configure a vanilla spark
cluster will supposed to Scala users but
for Python users you you really need to
think about what you're doing because
you
each Python each task is running in its
own Python process so you need to make
sure that each Python process has enough
memory if you allocate too much memory
to spark things won't work yeah sure
this is my last line having so like I
said I'm not going to go into loads of
detail come back to this if things start
to break you the take-home message from
this slide is that you need to make sure
that there is enough memory for your
Python processes to actually function
you can't give all of the memory of the
machines to spark which is the obvious
thing to do if you follow the
documentation literally that's probably
what you do it's not a good idea
ah this is not generic hiring it slide
this is um this is this is a real hiring
slide what we are really high with
people for my team so if you're
interested in this kind of distributed
machine learning on large datasets come
talk to me or send me an email thank you
and I'll take questions
no no it's robust offensive in color so
well the question was is it easy to
setup spark and then if a node breaks
does everything break or does things
robust so I my team we're R&D team so we
don't we don't necessarily make
production systems so if things break
you know no one really cares that much
but but we use what's known as the spark
ec2 scripts which comes with spark and
it enables you to launch a spot like an
ec2 cluster with spark installed really
really easily it's not super robust I
probably wouldn't use in a production
system but if you're doing data science
R&D type stuff then it's then it's very
easy and it works very well the second
question is spark robust it is robust if
a machine dies everything just flows
around
and computation gets really performed
when it's needed and computation you
know I keeps talking about this
partition concept the computation will
only occur for those partitions which
reside on that machine that they will
get rebuilt yep
hi I think you are using Python ipython
notebook it's not correct
I personally am NOT a Emacs but your
team and yeah and now I wanted to know
your experience in that we are
limitations you have found for example
can you run can you use any kind of
library in the notes when did I'm really
not the best person to talk to about
ipython notebook sorry I can connect you
to people in my team who who use it so
it come talk to me afterwards I'm
getting on to the lightning talks